welcome to the validation section
so we've seen so far
several different predictors which
given an x can predict for us what the
corresponding value of y should be
and i want to talk now about how we're
going to
evaluate different predictors
we have seen k nearest neighbors
predictors we've seen tree based
predictors
we've seen neural network predictors
we've seen linear predictors
and so somebody's come along and said
well here's my
favorite predictor which i designed and
you've got to decide well should i use
that predictor or should i use some
other predictor
so one of the key ideas is that we need
a
what's called a performance metric and
what it is is it's a measure of how
large
prediction errors are and so what we can
do is we can say well we've got a data
set
x1 to xn and y1 through yn
and for each one of those data points
we can evaluate the predictor g
at the ice data point x i to get a
prediction y hat i
and ask the question how close is y
hat i to y i
and the performance metric is going to
be the measure of how close y hat i is
to y i
and normally it's designed so that the
smaller the metric
the better the prediction performance
it's an error measure
some people call the prediction
performance metric the prediction
error as a result
so there are a few which are very
commonly used
the first one is the mean square error
so this here is the
two norm let me just mark it here
see the subscript two there what it
means
is it means means the following
if you give me a vector x
then
that's equal to the sum from i
is 1 up to n x
i squared or
square rooted and the subscript 2 there
indicates which particular norm
we are using um there are other norms
that we might use with different
subscripts
so for example we might use
the one norm which is just
the absolute value
of each of the components of x
added up
and we'll see a few other norms in this
class as well as a few other performance
metrics in this class
so if y i is a vector an
m dimensional vector then if you give me
a particular y
i and a particular corresponding
prediction y hat i
i can compute its two norm as
a measure of the error between y hat and
y i
and then i can average those up and um
so sum those up and divide by n and that
would be a
prediction performance metric
and of course if y i is just a scalar so
m is 1 then that's just the
mean square error the mean square
difference
between y i and y hat i
very often instead of working with the
mean square error we work with the root
mean square error
that is the square root of 1 on n
multiplied by the sum from i is 1 to n
of y
hat i minus y i squared
which is convenient because it has the
same units
as y and
uh another uh very useful
uh error metric or performance metric
is the mean absolute error so that's one
on n that sum from i is one to n of the
absolute value
of y hat i minus y of i
if you have scalar positive y's
then we define the mean fractional error
as the average of the absolute value
of y hat i minus y i divided by the
minimum
of y hat i and y i and this is something
like
an average percentage error
if y hat i is greater than y i then
the absolute value of y hat i minus y i
divided by the minimum of y hat i and y
high
is the percentage by which y hat i
is greater than y i
there are many other common performance
metrics
uh the median error um
there is another one that's very
commonly used and we'll see many others
in this class
so now that we've got a prediction
performance metric that allows us to
compare different predictors on a
particular data set
so for example we might conclude
that k nearest neighbors with ks7 does
better than k
nearest neighbors with k is 12.
or we might conclude that a particular
neural network does better than
a particular linear model um
several things to notice about these
kinds of conclusions they depend on
several things first of all they depend
on the performance metric it is
quite reasonable and quite common that
you can have a predictor that does
better
on one performance metric but does worse
in a different performance
performance metric so the neural network
may do better than the linear model when
using
the rms error but may do worse than the
linear model when using the mean
absolute error
so you've got to choose the performance
metric carefully so that it corresponds
to something that you actually care
about
another important thing to notice about
performance metrics and using them for
analysis of predictors is that they are
predictor agnostic that's a very good
thing
it means that when we evaluate the
performance of a predictor
we're not evaluating it using the same
software that was used
to develop it we're not evaluating it on
the basis of the properties
of the learning algorithm we're
evaluating it on some
objective notion of performance and
anybody's predictor could be evaluated
using the same performance measure so if
somebody else has a
method of generating a predictor even if
you don't know what that method is
you can evaluate their predictor by
evaluating the quality of their
predictions
and all that should matter is whether or
not their
predictions do better are better
than predictions given by some other
predictor
a third thing to notice about comparing
predictors using a performance metric is
that it depends
on the data set and so
all you can do is you can use the
performance metric
to evaluate the performance of a
predictor on a particular
data set
and that leads us to the question of
generalization
suppose we have a predictor and it
performs well
on the data set that we use to train it
can we conclude that it's going to
perform well
on a data set that it's never seen
before
unseen data and if it does that's called
generalization generalization
is the ability of a predictor to perform
well on unseen data
and unseen here means that the data was
not used to create the prediction model
it was not part of the learning data set
the person who developed the predictor
never looked at that data when they were
developing the predictor
so we'd like to answer the question of
when
we can infer that good performance
of a predictor on one data set implies
that the perform the predictor will
perform well on a second data set
and in order to do that one will need to
make some probabilistic assumptions
for example one might say that both sets
of data
are samples from some underlying
probability distribution
with some kind of probabilistic
assumptions like that
we might well be able to include the
performance on one data set
says something about performance on
another data set for example
if we have two sets of data both sampled
from the same distribution we might
reasonably conclude that the mean
of the first set of data and the mean of
the second set of data
should be very close provided we have
enough data
so there is a
framework for doing this kind of
analysis we will
not discuss it in this class it's a more
advanced topic
but instead what we will see is we will
see some practical practical methods
some methods for actually assessing
whether or not the prediction that
you've got actually generalizes
the fundamental thing to do of course if
you want to know whether your predictor
generalizes to a new set of data
is to try it out on a new set of data
and so we think about having two sets of
data
one we call the training data or the in
sample data and that's the data set that
we use
in order to construct the predictor and
then we have another set of data which
we call
the out of sample data that's the unseen
data
on which we're going to test the
performance of the predictor
and if the predictor performs well on
this unseen data
we say the predictor generalizes it
makes good predictions on data
it is never seen
if it doesn't we say it fails to
generalize it's
over fit this terminology overfit is
quite evocative and we will have much
more to say about it
okay here is a simple example this is
data downloaded from the
federal government uh these this plot
shows the number of vehicle miles
traveled
in each year over a range of years from
1970 to 2005.
and so vehicle miles traveled is the
total number of miles
traveled over the year by all of the
vehicles
um and on the left here
we have a subset of the data we have 12
data points i will just highlight
right there and what we do with those 12
data points
is we fit a straight line predictor y
hat is theta 1 plus theta 2 times x
where y hat is our prediction of the
number of vehicle miles traveled
and x is the year and we'll just choose
those parameters using least squares
that gives us this nice straight line
fit
here
which goes all the way
up there and then we can say well
um let's look at the rest of the data
the data that we held aside
we we only fit this straight line using
blue sample points we've got another 14
data points
those are these 14 data points right
here
and we can see that those 14 data points
actually lie rather close
to the straight line fit
and so the predictor actually does
generalize to those
additional points
of course in this simple example you can
plot it all and see it all by eye
it's very simple in two dimensions and
of course we'd like to be able to work
with very large data sets in a very
large number of dimensions
where it's no longer possible to do such
simple plots
that's why we need to use the tool of a
prediction error metric prediction
performance metric
in order to evaluate how well the
perform the predictor is doing on these
different data sets
now there's a specific approach to doing
this in fact there are several specific
approaches
to doing this kind of analysis the first
one is called out of sample validation
and that goes like this very often we
don't
have data sets which are naturally fall
into
two categories data that we use to
do the training and data that we use to
test and so what we do is we
split the data and so we'll download
some data set it may be
a whole bunch of images and we'd like to
develop a predictor that can look at an
image and tell us whether that's a cat
or that's a dog
and
we take this data and we divide the data
into two data sets
a training set and a test set
and often we do that randomly so we'll
might use 80
uh an 80 20 split where 80 of the points
we use for training and 20 will use for
test
now we might use 90 10 it doesn't really
matter very much the exact
uh split is not very important and the
results are quite incentive insensitive
to that
what we do with the training set is we
train the predictor
we use it to choose the predictor
and then the test set is used to
validate the predictor to evaluate how
well
the predictor performs using the
particular performance metric we've
decided upon
and as a result you have an honest test
you have an honest simulation of how the
predictor
works on unseen data
and we hope that because
it worked well on data that was not used
to train it
it will also work well on other unseen
data
that we haven't seen yet at all
and this hope is founded on the
assumption that all of this data looks
kind of the same
the data that we used for training the
data that we're using for testing and
future unseen data they're all kind of
similar
very often we do this split in a random
way
for two reasons
one is is that we want to get the
training right
and so
if i'm for example outside taking
photographs of cats and dogs
in hope to develop a predictor that can
tell the difference between them
well during the day the sun might go
down the clouds might come over
it might become quite overcast the
conditions can change quite
significantly
and so if i simply take the last 20 of
the images
then i could end up with a test set
which is all cloudy images
and a training set which is all sunny
images
and that will both upset my
training it could well be that my
predictor will not
learn how to distinguish cats and dogs
under cloudy conditions but only under
sunny conditions
and alarm set might upset my test in
that all i will be doing is testing
the predictor and clarity conditions and
i won't measure the performance in sunny
conditions
so the fact that you make this split
random helps to avoid these kinds of
uh biases and errors which are a result
of a particular ordering of the data in
the data set
now what matters is the performance
on the test set
the training set performance doesn't
really matter at all
we expect it to be good and in fact we
usually expect the
uh the training performance to be better
than the test performance
um usually the test performance is only
a little bit worse than the training
performance
sometimes the test performance is still
okay but actually quite a lot worse than
the training performance
that's fine if your test performance is
okay that's what matters
you can be in a situation where the
training performance is perfect
for example one nearest neighbor's
predictor the one nearest neighbor's
predictor if you give it an element of
the training set one of the xi's
it predicts the corresponding y i
corresponding to that x i
because that is the closest x
to that x i and so it gets zero
error on the training set
but it still makes useful predictions
even for
data that's not in the training set but
the training error is no
indicator of how well it will do on the
test set
so let's look at how we interpret
validation results
we have two measurements the first is
the performance on the test set
that's really what matters and the
second is the performance on the
training set
that doesn't matter and so we get four
numbers
we'll plot these in a table here yeah in
the first column
we have the training error we have small
training error
and in the second column we have large
and in the first row we have small test
error and in the second where we have
large test error
so this top left entry here
is really good news it means we got
small test error and small training
error
so it performs well when we did our
training and then when we tried it out
on data we haven't seen before it did
well there too and so it generalizes
it is possible to be over here
to be in the case where we have small
test error
but large training error that is
luck or perhaps we've cheated and
there's some kind of fraud involved
um it doesn't happen very often because
when does the training and once
a large training error and typically
doesn't even we don't even bother to try
it against unseen data
if we can't get it to work on data that
we can see we're probably not going to
get it to work on data that we
can't see so this doesn't happen very
often
now if we have large test error the
bottom row
well then there's two possible
explanations
one is where we have small training
error
but we had large test error
this is the failure to generalize we
thought we developed a good predictor it
seemed to do well when we were training
it
but then we tested it on data we've
never seen before and it didn't do well
um we would say such a predictor is over
fit
and then the worst case of all we have
large training error and large test
error
it generalizes okay you know it does the
same thing on the test data that it does
on the
the training data but it doesn't do very
well on the training data
so how do we choose between different
candidate predictors
two people come along they've both
they're both experts in machine learning
and they come to us with their
predictors but they've developed them
using completely different methods
we don't even get to see their code
we can do validation we take their
predictors
and we try their predictors on data that
they've never seen before
and typically what we're going to do is
we're going to choose the predictor
amongst all of those candidates
which has the smallest test error
that's not always what we do because
sometimes
we're willing to back off a little bit
on that requirement we might accept a
little bit larger test error
if that gives us a particularly simpler
predictor
there are good reasons for this and we
will
have more to say on this later
let's look at a particular example here
is simply a one-dimensional example
we have uh a data set
with 30 data points um 20 of which we'll
use for training and 10 of which we'll
use as the test set
here on this plot we see 20 blue points
those are the
training set in 10 red points
so here is the performance of two of our
favorite
classes of predictors on that data set
here on the top row we have the k
nearest neighbor predictors
when k is one two and three and on the
bottom row we have
the affine predictor the quadratic
predictor and the cubic predictor
we can see right here that the in the in
the top left
plot the k nearest neighbors wing
predictor when k is one does perfectly
on the training data let me just
highlight that it passes perfectly
through
the blue data points
if i look at the k is equal to 2 plot
well that doesn't pass perfectly through
all the data points
but it's a bit smoother than the k is
equal to one
and k is equal to three also doesn't
pass through all the data points
but it's a little bit smoother than k is
equal to two
now the alpha predictor here it's the
best straight line fit
here's the quadratic predictor
and here's the cubic predictor
just looking at these
now let's look at the rms performance
error
so we're using the rms error here as the
performance metric
and we could say well which is the best
prediction model
some things to highlight well first of
all
that number right there is zero the k
nearest neighbor's predictor when k is
equal to one that's perfectly on the
training data
um doesn't when we increase k is equal
to
k is equal to three actually the
performance gets worse on the training
data
um and on the test data
it changes a little bit it goes from
point one when k is one to point zero
eight when k is two back up to point one
when k is three
when we look at the polynomial
predictors
we see something which is quite
interesting
with an rfi predictor on the training
data we have 0.08
and then when we go to the quadratic
predictor the error decreases
this has to happen because
we're optimizing over the best possible
quadratic
predictor and of course an alpha
predictor is a quadratic
predictor it's just a very special one
and so
the quadratic predictor is comparing all
possible quadratics
including all the athens and so it has
to do at least as well as the best alpha
predictor
so when we go from alpha to quadratic
the performance has to get better
and the same when we go from quadratic
to cubic
every quadratic predictor is a cubic
predictor and so
the best cubic predictor must do at
least as well as the best quadratic
predictor
and so the train the training error has
to decrease as we go from afrin to
quadratic to cubic
that those statements aren't true for
the test data
we do see that as we go
from affine to quadratic to cubic
that the performance on the test data
does get better
but there's no guarantee that that would
happen it doesn't have to happen
so out of all of these predictors which
one has the best test
error is this one right here
that's noticeably better that's the
cubic
predictor it's test error 0.025
the next comparable ones are
the quadratic predictor and the two
nearest neighbor
predictor but those are substantially
worse at point zero eight
so we might decide to go for
the best the the cubic predictor which
does well in test
and it does well in train
and so it both performs well and
generalizes well
we have the k nearest neighbor with k is
equal to one
which performs well on the train but
doesn't generalize so well
let's look more generally at polynomial
fits
so suppose we have a scalar u and scalar
v
as our raw data and then we use a
feature mapping
where we construct x's from u's by x is
equal to phi of u
and for each u we construct a d
dimensional vector
consisting of the powers of u 1
u u squared up to u to the power of d
minus 1.
and then we're going to construct a
linear predictor g of x
theta transpose x a linear combination
of those d monomials a polynomial of
degree d minus one
and we're going to choose the theta by
least squares
and here's the kind of thing that we see
here we have 60 data points and
we are looking at the predictors with d
is equal to 6
on the left in the middle of d is equal
to 12 and on the right d is equal to 14.
so these are degree 5 degree 11 and
degree 13
polynomial fits of the data
now if we look at the rms error the one
that has the smallest rms error
is the degree 13 plot
and that's not surprising at all for the
same reason the cubic did better than
the quadratic in the previous example
the degree 13 has to do better than the
degree 11 which has to do better than
the degree 5
against the training data
now we'll take those same 60 data points
and we'll split the data points into 48
training points and 12 test points
now for each degree d between here
we've got degrees between 0 and 14.
what we're going to do is we're going to
train
a predictor on the 48 data points
and then we'll compute two numbers it's
rms error
on the training set and it's rms error
on the test set
so for degree 2
that's this number and
this number and then we do it again
say it degree 4 and we end up with this
number
and this number we expect
that the training error is going to be
less
it's going to be less than the test
error and it is
at every different degree that we see
here but it doesn't have to be that way
these two cur these two plots can
certainly
cross it usually happens that we do
better in training than we do in tests
but not always
now what happens on the training set as
you increase the degree
is that the
training error has to decrease
increasing the class of functions
increasing the set of functions over
which we're optimizing
means we're going to get better fits and
so you can see that every time we
increase degree
the training error decreases
the test error certainly doesn't have to
and it doesn't
now if you just looked at the training
error
you might conclude we should conclude we
should use
a degree as high as possible so we
should use d
is equal to 15 here
and ah
however if you look at the test error
that suggests quite a different story
that suggests that
we should use
degree five
what's happening out here to the right
is we're seeing overfitting we're seeing
predictors that are doing really well
on the training data but much less well
on the test data
let's look at our plots again
so here we can see it you can just about
see
that really this data is kind of noisy
and there's plots points scattered
everywhere
but here we've seen these little wiggles
showing up
let's look at our polynomial fit again
to see if we can see evidence
of overfitting
so there's two things that show up on
this plot that are interesting
one is is that there seems to be quite a
lot of noise in the data
what do i mean by that if we look at
just a particular region let's look at
this region
if i look at x's within this region
here then we can see that vertically
the value of y still tends to have some
variability
it's not a smooth curve like the
predictor
would have us believe
but instead the points jiggle up and
down a lot now it suggests that those
points come about
that variation in those vertical
position of those points
comes about due to noise now
what's happening with regard to our
predictor
our predictor is doing something
interesting our predictor
in this degree five plot is just sort of
averaging out the noise it's doing
something rather gentle
it's just moving gently through
the center of the cloud of the points
but this predictor over here
at degree 13 we can see that it's
starting to wiggle
and the reason it's starting to wiggle
is that it's starting to believe in the
noise it's starting to try and
fit the noise and this is what we mean
by overfitting
the learning algorithm is
fitting a predictor to features of the
training data
which are due to noise or variation
which isn't present in the test set
and that's what we see is that as we
move down here
we're getting better and better fit as
we fit more and more closely the
features
in the training data but the reality is
is that with test data we're going to
move
up here and we're going to find that
those features
don't actually exist in the test data
and they are going to give us greater
error in the test data
than we are led to believe by the
performance in the training data
now we can do several more slightly more
sophisticated things
than simply split the data into a test
set and a training set
one extension is to split the data
more ways so we split the data into k
different subsets we'll call them k
folds of the data
and this is called k-fold cross
validation
and so we have k different buckets of
data
okay different subsets of the data
and what we're going to do is we're
going to go through
that's the sets of data and the first
time we fit
so let's draw safe with respect suppose
k is 5
and then we'll have five different
subsets of the data there's one
there's two there's three there's four
and there's five the first time we fit
we will fit using
those four and we'll test
using that one the second time we fit
we will we will fit using this one
those four and test using that one
the third time will fit
using those four and test using that one
and so on so we'll have each time
we do a run we will train using
four out of our five buckets of data and
we're going to test using the other
bucket of the data
as a result we get rather than having
just one test error and one training
error
we have five different training
errors and five different corresponding
test errors
these five different test errors we can
look at we can
work out the mean test error the
standard deviation of the test errors
and just get a sense of the variation if
they're all small
then we can feel rather confident that
actually this predictor
does well conversely if there's a whole
lot of variability then we start to feel
a little less confident
and of course we haven't really got one
predictor we're going to have if ks5
five different predictors and so we can
look
at the different thetas the different
predictor parameters if they were all
very similar
there's another reason to feel confident
that our methods are giving us
a certain amount of uniformity
we're getting the same predictor for
each one of our different subsets of the
data
on the other hand if the predictor
parameters vary wildly
well then we're less confident
that we've got a sensible choice of
predictor coming out of our method
here's an example this is just randomly
generated data
you can see here on the left we have
fitted a
a straight line
through the data so that's determined by
two parameters
theta one plus theta two times x is the
predictor
and uh and then we do we split the data
five ways
and do five-fold cross-validation
that gives us five different results
each of which
is a training loss and it has a training
loss and a test loss
and we can see that well typically
the test loss oh it's not that different
from the training loss
that's a good sign right there
and there's some variability in the test
loss the test smallest test loss we see
here is point
zero zero two seven the largest test
loss is
point zero zero seven one but this
that's
either way it's still very small
the theta parameters we also see some
variability there in particular in theta
one but it's
rather a small number again it's going
to be
0.003 up to 0.01 0.012
up to minus 0.012 and see the 2 is about
1.
you can see that of course when we plot
the
different predictors each of the
different predictors those are really
five different plots here
on this curve there are really five
lines on top of each other
but they're also close to each other
that we can't really tell the difference
of course when you're in high dimensions
you can't necessarily plot your
predictors but you can look at theta one
and the the different theta parameters
and you can look at the training loss
and the test loss
we might want to be even more confident
than simply having five different
results
here's how you might do that you take
the data
and split it into a training and test
split say 80 20
but completely randomly train the
predictor using the training data
and then evaluate the predictor on the
test data
and then repeat it again a thousand
different times
so here's how you might gain a little
bit more confidence
you might split the data into a training
and test split
say 80 20 randomly
then you train the predictor using the
training data
and you evaluate it on the test data
now you repeat that a thousand times
and then you'll have a thousand
different
test errors
you can pull the histogram of those test
errors and see
how much variation is there and we can
see right here
that the mean test error
in this example is about point zero five
and if we look back to our previous data
it's not that inconsistent between where
we
saw errors between point 0.027 and 0.071
and couple here around .05
and so really we can be confident that
when we try this on new
test data we would expect to see
something around point zero five at
least if our
lo of our entire data set is
representative of unseen data
and we can also see that there's going
to be some variation even with a data
set the size that we have
we're going to see sometimes we're going
to see some significant
test errors of 0.015.02
okay one last topic in this section and
that is what you do once you've chosen
a predictor
well one thing you have to be careful of
is that
you've revisited this test set too many
times
even if you kept one test set in escrow
you trained
based on the date on the training set
and then you evaluated your predictor on
the test set and you decided that the
project wasn't very good
well suddenly you're taking information
from
that test set and using it in your
training procedure
and when you do it again and again and
again information is leaking
from the test set into your training
procedure
you're learning based in part on the
test set
and so it's no longer a really honest
simulation of how well the model will do
on data you've never seen
of course there's a trick to avoid this
and the trick to avoid this is to split
the original data instead of into two
data sets into three data sets
a training set that's how we fit
multiple candidate models
a validation data set which we evaluate
the performance of our models on
and then a test data set which is
pristine it's untouched
we keep it to one side and we never look
at it
or we look at it once that tells us how
well we've done
but then we don't go back and chain our
change our predictor once we've looked
at it
this of course is a little bit more
honest
some people will say that it's taking it
to extremes
and this really depends on how much
leakage of information there is
from your test set into your training
set from your validation set into your
training set
now some practitioners do this others do
not also the
names of test and validation are
not really well settled
some people reverse the terminology and
refer to the pristine set as the
validation set
and the test set as the thing that's
used to evaluate the performance of
models
in this course we won't go to this
extreme we'll simply use
one test set and one validation set
and we'll use out-of-sample or five-fold
cross-validation
one more thing you can do is that you're
satisfied at the end of the day you've
you've done train validation and test
and you've got a predictor that you're
pretty happy with
now you could just stop there and say
that's a predictor we're going to use it
and we're happy with it another thing
you can do is you can say well
what we've really validated is not the
predictor
but the procedure the learning algorithm
which we're using to develop the
predictor
and so why not just take that learning
algorithm which we're happy with
and now apply it to the whole data set
so that it can learn
from all of the data we have not just
the piece that we used for training
and that is a very common practice
[Music]
and uh there's nothing wrong with it it
works very well
uh many people do this um
so for example you might train k nearest
neighbor predictors for various values
of k
validation suggests that ks6 is a good
choice
now the final predictor you supply is a
k nearest neighbor's predictor with ks6
but it uses all of the data
okay in this section we've talked about
evaluating
predictors
in the previous section we talked about
different predictors that we could have
um we've yet to talk about how you might
make predictors and how you might learn
and that's
of course coming in this class but right
now
you're in a position where
if somebody gives you a predictor you
can decide
whether it's good or not but also you're
in a position where
the stage for the court for this course
has been
set we know what we're trying to do now
with this class
we're trying to develop predictors we
know how
once we've got predictors how we're
going to evaluate them how we're going
to tell
good predictors from bad predictors and
what's next is to
go ahead and make something